Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to see progress
in text to image research that is so
incredible it hardly seems believable. So,
what is text to image? Simple - these are
AI-based techniques where a text prompt from
us goes in, and a beautiful image comes out.
There are already a large set of techniques
that can perform text to image really well,
for instance, OpenAI’s DALL-E 2 can do it, where
we wait approximately 10 seconds for each image.
Or, we can even run it on our own hardware
with the free and open source Stable Diffusion.
So, are we done? What else is there to invent
here? Why write more papers? Well, by the time
you finish this video, I hope you will agree with
me that the only possible answer is: my goodness,
there is so much to be done and so
much that has just been improved.
For instance, this new technique from Google that
they call Muse can perform mask-free editing too.
What is that? To be able to appreciate what
that is, let’s look at what mask-based editing
looks like. Imagine that we have a wonderful
photo here, but we would like to change the
location of the background. No matter, let’s just
highlight this region, which we will call a mask,
and ask for a different background. And, yes, it
can repaint the image as if it were in New York,
Paris, or San Francisco. Wonderful. This is image
inpainting by using a mask and a text prompt.
And now, let’s do this, but without a mask!
What? How is this even possible? Well,
we can tell the AI, come on, you are smart enough
to know where these objects are and what they are,
so, you do the masking yourself.
Automatically. So, can it? Let’s see.
There is a cake in this image, and a
coffee latte. But, psst! Don’t tell the
AI where it is. Confidential information. Let it
find out itself. Now, little AI, please change
the cake to a croissant, if it even exists,
who knows, the latte art should form a flower.
And… wow. Look at that. Who could say that this
was not the original image? It has done absolutely
amazing. And, I am a light transport researcher
by trade, so I cannot resist mentioning that
the specular highlights on the new plate
are also excellent. Good job, little AI!
But its mask free editing capabilities
can do even better. Look. We can change
our clothes super easily, even with text,
remember, synthesizing text properly was
quite difficult for previous techniques,
and this just does it easily. So good!
Now, get this, because we can also do this with
drawings, and if we do, something amazing happens.
Look. We can start out from a crude drawing
of a cat, and ask it to morph into different
other animals. And through this, it can become a
dog, or a pig, a raccoon, or even other animals.
This is possible because this new technique is
not your usual diffusion-based process like many
previous image generators. What does that mean?
It means that it does not start out from noise and
does not reorganize this noise to get a coherent
image. It does not think in terms of noise at all.
But, we are not done yet, not even close! It
can also perform image outpainting. That is,
taking this part of the image and replacing
the entirety of the image around it using a
text prompt. Travel around the world
with just one text prompt. So cool!
Now, have a look at these images and
their prompts. Great works, right? But,
there is something that ties them together. Do
you know what? Well, hold on to your papers,
because all of these images took just
approximately one second to generate.
That’s right, this is up to 10 times
faster than previous techniques! And
all this less than a year after DALL-E
2 has been published. That is insanity.
And it can also perform things that other
previous techniques had a great deal of
trouble with. What are those? Well, two examples,
cardinality and composition. Cardinality means
that if we ask for three elephants standing
on top of each other, we really get three.
If we ask for four bottles of wine, we get
four. And if we ask for 10 bottles of wine,
wait a minute…yes, apparently not
even this technique is perfect.
It also does well when it comes to composition.
If we ask for the two baseballs to be to the left
of the tennis balls, the AI understands that
and thus, they will likely end up being there.
However, I also love how it combines all of
these these concepts together. For instance,
here, we can do mask-free editing while keeping
the composition of the original image the same.
This way, we can transform our cat into
a dog, change a small basketball into an
American football, or make our cat yawn, or even
change these flowers. And note that we did not
need a mask for this, no highlighting
regions where the cats and roses are,
we just write what we want and the AI does it!
Also note once again that the composition of the
original image remains intact. I absolutely
love this. Such an amazing tool, and now,
a really fast one too. One second for
each of these? Sign me up right now!
And just imagine that two more papers down
the line perhaps all this will be possible
to do in real time. We might be able to create
little virtual worlds with the speed of thought.
How cool is that! What a time to be alive!
So, what do you think? What would you use
this for? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!